theo is always worried he wants to keep
this show current keep us hip
uh so make sure trends don't pass us by
i invited a tick-tock superstar here
uh to come and explain some of the
newest tick-tock tricks is he of age or
she of age
just barely you wouldn't tell it he's
very
very
young looking skin but while you come on
in
young looking skin superstar that's a
loose start
super true damn [ __ ] up the wires
what's up dog
did you did you knock the [ __ ] over no
no no no
you didn't you could take a cat spot
what's up young fella what's up brandon
how you doing oh not the kicks the
barons all right
how are you doing one barons dude we got
a real tick tock star that's dope as
[ __ ]
loose
uh i thought i thought everybody's seen
this kid on ticket talk before
what's up theo what's up playboy how are
you doing man oh good how are you
we sat you next to chappelle so you
could ride it home
[Laughter]
damn i'm going to get canceled this
podcast
you won't man brendan i don't know if
you know giolani we're really proud of
him he's in a
power book ghost too he's in a new uh
series on stars that works for 50 cent
the guy who got shot and
murdered but came back to life the guy
who's pro-trump
right movies that's a good point
first of all theo you uh a long time ago
you said he was in the book of mormon
50 cent no i had the title wrong
he's like yeah gianni ladies and
gentlemen yeah it is a show
here is little pimp
is here did you buy a lamborghini uh not
yet no
they gave that to me for like a couple
uh a couple weeks to drive around all i
had to do was post about it oh you're
just stunting with it yeah i just
pretended like it was mine
all right that's very 50 cent there he
is right there
j crew obviously who's that who's that
new age
urkel behind you
no that's my homie michael rainey jr
he's he's my co-star on on the show
oh yeah i thought they redid family
matters tossed a white guy in finally
called all families matter
if you watch some of gianni's uh
instagram videos he's always just
like he basically will film michael
randy and then just laugh at him for no
reason
basically ninety percent of their
relationship but
gianni we want to know what's it like to
how do you get into tick-tocking and
what do you need to do
yeah me and theo too old for it no i see
i i ran theo's tick tock for like
uh three four months and he got like i
think
300k like that quick and then i ran
santino's and got him like a half a mil
in like a couple months
the good one okay okay wow
you're what's known as a ghost tick
tocker yeah literally
yeah it's easy because i think i found
you another gig because i need to get on
there with shows like this and um
and like bad friends obviously it's so
easy because you just pull like 40
second clips
and people think it's funny like there
was a there was one video with santino
and bobby where santino was making fun
of bobby that he
ate his cat that died it was like pretty
like baseline i thought it was funny but
i posted it and it got like 10 million
views and i think he got a hundred
thousand followers just from
jesus christ the way tick-tock works is
literally like a wildfire it's like once
it hits somewhere like it goes
everywhere and viral
yeah you'll go viral like quick and then
you'll get no followers for like a
couple weeks until you post something
interesting now is there a lot of people
on tick tock yeah
see it's so interesting because the way
tick tock works is like you're
for you page there's a for you page
which is like suggested videos and
there's a following
so it's like what who you follow so say
for example your for you page is going
to look so different than brennan's
because he'll be liking different things
got it so yeah this dude genius doug
yeah so basically like yeah if you like
a ton of you know
like black comedy videos like that's
kind of what whoa whoa whoa what makes
you say that
he asked if it was tick tock it was
black he asked if there was a lot of
black people on tick tock
i'm trying to make me feel racist
because you are theo yeah
legit point legit point legit point look
don't look at chappella's a cranberries
fan okay so let's be honest
zombies theo's got a bandana around his
neck you know he's racist
so uh gianni brought some uh tick tocks
uh i don't know if these are your
favorites or just ones that are popping
off or
yeah so a lot of the trends it's so
weird because something will happen for
like someone will post something it'll
go viral and then everyone will do it
for two days and it's gone and then it's
gone
so that's kids these days man uh this
was this one i
just thought that was really funny and
for chappelle
thank you
[Laughter]
yeah that's great
that's awesome yeah gianni what about
what about one of yours where um
okay so sorry take me through a little
more so that one comes out and then
people make similar ones to it
yeah so i mean that one was kind of a
one-off like people
didn't start kind of going on that but i
think i gave nick
one of them but the mark cuban made one
where he
it was like a certain sound like people
know like oh this is the noise
so this is what goes what's the content
with this tick tock
so mark cuban like recorded his daughter
daughter and he was like uh
he was like i own a basketball team and
she can't make a free throw for [ __ ]
so then everyone's parents started
getting on this trend and then
it would be like a black guy like
recording his son and being like
you know he's six foot three and and
he's not an athlete at all like just
kind of stuff like that of like
parents [ __ ] on their kids so it's
like it's the trends with the sound
damn so you gotta stay up on it you do
you have to be looking like if you want
to do it for as a legit job you need to
be looking at it
every day like what's the trend and and
the thing is like it's more about
quantity than quality like you'll post
10 in a day
and like one will pop off and get 100
million and you're like [ __ ] it like i
don't care about the other ones
it's not like instagram damn and
so with your amount of following are you
are you making money on it or not yet
uh i mean i've got i've done a couple
things where i was like okay i'll post
this like for
you know a couple thousand dollars but
i'm not like legit doing it as a job
i'll just
if someone offers me something i'd be
like okay if it makes sense i'll do it
got it but yeah it's so weird because
even with that type of following
i'll post something and it'll only get
like four or five thousand views if it
doesn't go viral
even with that following like as opposed
to instagram like kind of got to get in
the algorithm
exactly yeah and and if you post like
offensive things like i do
then um they'll shadow ban you and then
all your stuff won't go viral at all
my little brother got his tic-tock taken
away because he posted his balls um
oh yeah you can't post any of that stuff
like instagram thoughts can't post their
titties and stuff no
nothing i mean they do a lot of like
stuff in in clothes but
they're young so i don't look at those
do you [ __ ] do you [ __ ] do you [ __ ]
with only fans too
um as in what do i like have one or do i
have nothing
hey hold on hey i guess what i'm asking
is do you run theo's only fan page too
it's just naked videos of me
damn daddy don't button down too low now
patreon patreon
all right uh now i will say this a lot
of gianni's uh
talks what do we call them ticks or what
do we call them yeah tick tocks
tick ticks yeah okay there's no like
shortened names
a lot of johnny's talks are making are
really waking his brother up out of a
dead sleep and uh
telling him there's something's wrong
see that one right there so this is how
crazy tick-tock can be see that matthew
mcconaughey one
i posted that and then it went so viral
that um barstool picked it up people
magazine picked it up
and then it was the number one trending
thing on twitter just because i posted
this
but it really it's not it's not even
creative you just you just posted the
video of them doing a table reading
literally i was just i made it you're
just the first one
yeah i was making an instagram story
because i was actually watching it
because i wanted to watch it yeah it's
dope and then i just posted like three
or four instagram stories like oh this
is funny i'll put this on tick tock
literally two hours later everyone
started picking it up barstool
morgan freeman looked like [ __ ] crazy oh
what are you talking about bernie he
looks like morgan freaking freeman
yeah he does it looks like an unwrapped
mummy
[Laughter]
so so we have some some tick-tockers
that like i don't think anybody in this
room has heard of
except uh gianni so uh why don't you
like got to give us the
info on who who some of these people are
addison ray
okay yeah so she dates um bryce hall
and they're like the tick tock like
couple power couple
yeah the same thing it's like addison
ray and then like there's um
dixie demilio which is charlie's sister
and she dates um that that other kid uh
noah beck
are these jesus are these people adults
yeah these people are
but are of age charlie is not she's 16.
and are they only
famous because they do short take talk
videos see the worst part about it is
they're only famous and it's
they don't even do anything funny or
creative they literally just like dance
and stick out their tongue but she's
super hot
addison's i think addison's beautiful
but i mean it's like
i could do it that's her there yeah
she's all right
yeah that's what i'm saying but it's
like but it's like hundreds of millions
of dollars for like
it's like crazy how does she make so
much money because she gets
67 million followers yeah four points
and all she does
that's all they do is they literally
just dance next to each other 40 million
that's those two
yeah that's um bryce
he's a [ __ ] boy huh could not be more of
a fun
he's like the prototype of what kids
this age no
but see it's so crazy because now so
there's another kid in the hype house
which is they all live together and they
make tick tocks together
and there's this kid josh richards and
now he has a podcast with prez from
barstool
oh i watched it because i'm you know
barcelona my boys and
prez i watched i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on but see prez is smart because
he wants to capitalize on it but he only
really posts
the clips on tick tock so he wants to
get he knows because their views aren't
like great on there i'm like why is he
doing this he's doing it
because the algorithm if you have those
people in it because basically that's
what
makes tick tock so you know famous and
everyone's talking about because all the
kids are watching it
so if you're in a video with them it's
automatically just pumped to the future
wow that's insane and then immediately
dave portnoy just started
getting in feuds with all of them so
he's like he's like he knows what he
wants yeah
yeah yeah so talk some [ __ ] about some
tick tockers she's like the joker yeah
all she did all they did was they just
did body rolls literally so the ones
that i gave nick
the ones i gave nick are like the
creative funny ones and i'm like oh this
is hilarious but those people aren't
tick-tock stars they're just people that
went viral one time yeah
the people who just danced like that are
the ones who have all these followers
and all they do is just use someone
else's sound
someone else made up the dance and then
didn't some like big music
like not just like one hit wonders come
from tick tock like
tick tock beats then they take those
beats and make a single out of it yeah
didn't tyga do that
i i think he did do that at one point
because tyga is pretty big on tick tock
um like some rappers are on the chris
brown like a lot of these people are
hopping on because they're like i want
to get
i want to get on the track you know what
i mean because yeah the other stuff is
going away and then now they're like we
have to keep with the time so it's crazy
that people already
hey man leo can you body roll now what
is this
this is this is the tick tock that got
my little brother's account banned
nice so there was a thing called the
vogue challenge where people would just
post pictures of themselves with the
vote cover it looked like the cover of
magazine
so this is what happened this is your
little brother and we're gonna have to
blur something out on youtube
yeah okay oh he just says dig out yeah
theo close your eyes but open my mouth
that got him banned no way
[Laughter]
hey theo's mouth is drooling
that's the first time theo's watched
porn in like three months
he tricked him into it i know right i'll
just say this man
it could have been a yam
[Laughter]
it's not a sin if you got tricked into
it he should read an email to tick-tock
and be like that was a yeah he did no
you know what he actually did he called
my publicist behind my back and
she reached out to tick-tock behind my
back and was like trying to like
figure it out and then they're like nah
his balls are out we can't fix it
but then i found out a couple months
later like she told me i was like you
called my publicist
like my pr firm like she's like i'm like
she's like we don't want to deal with
this dude yeah yeah that's clearly
you're not
yeah yeah yeah did she really look at
the trick is you take a hair dryer to a
yam and say that you're nuts
no okay take a haircut
village trick uh what else should we
play here gianni
um i mean a lot of them are like there
are some feel good ones that like i
actually like and
make you know make me feel better which
one which one i know this isn't this
past weekend we don't talk about our
feelings but go to the the one
of the guy the guy dancing that uh yeah
that one the guy sitting down on the
desk
this no no unbelievable that's not the
one that one dude this is my favorite
one
yeah i love this one it's just like i
don't know i just i just really like
you're on take time no no i've seen it
on instagram
he breaks it down
[Music]
oh he's good
oh damn
[Music]
he's good
hell yeah
as you can see my for you page is
obviously very black as well so oh okay
there you go
hell yeah um and gianni there's rumors
that you're going to get your skin
died to be black is that
no no no i i i am the token white guy
on the show so and it needs to say that
way
yeah right yeah right we need one person
to represent our community
you know mm-hmm what's this one and
what's this one yeah oh that's the one
we saw with the guy with the
was the one of the girls says
millenniums be like oh that one's really
funny
coming back up i think that's that's um
maybe like alec baldwin's daughter but i
could be wrong
that one of that girl haley baldwin or
ireland
ireland yeah yeah you're right her
name's ireland
i am waiting tuesday i am fading
on a wednesday i can't sleep
hi it's trap bunny
booty clint i want to bang your death
and kill him
can't i'll be winners yeah i can't
enough
i love that first song though her dad's
a beast though huh
you know yeah you can't they can't all
win you know uh
how hip are we now though i feel i feel
pretty i've never felt older
i'm also gonna hire gianni though after
this yeah yeah we're
we're freaking hip replacement dude if
anything um
now now i feel like gianni would you
tell us who would have the best tick
tock career
and take us in an order uh from from
worst to best between our group here
oh i like this um i would say
i mean you kind of have really weird
things that are like out there so people
are thinking are funny so pro i mean i
would say you and brandon because you
also have the most content already
don't throw brendan in with me well i'm
just saying like like
like any clip from king in this thing
like could go viral if you post five of
them i bet you you'd get
20 million views just from the funniest
clips that you guys have
well we're going to start doing to be
doing that but you have but
you also have more solo things which
people like to see as well so
um which brennan obviously you don't do
a solo podcast although you do below the
belt and something like that
so that would like that's more fights
but people it's interesting because
there is a fight community on tick-tock
really that would be your audience so
you could
it won't be as big of a of a fan base
but there
is like niche and it will be it's like
it's like
uh twitter you can kind of find
communities for any sport and
there's becoming like an mma tick tock
and you'd be early if you had people
from
uh below the belt making tick tocks just
like you got to add stuff like you're
talking about a fighter but then like
have stats come up at the same time like
there's a way to hack it that'd be cool
praise god so then and then i'd probably
go cat because she'll
wear her tank tops and it'll go viral
um and then i'd go chappelle because
there's a lot of diversity going on now
in the industry so a lot of diverse like
this is a lot of diversity theo we're
down to two people on the playground
yeah this is like your freaking
basketball piece yeah this is a
no-brainer come on
i don't know ching's trigger if chin had
on his dangly earring he'd do well yeah
but nick does have nick does have a lot
of content from uh
another bachelor podcast nobody knows
giovanni but
uh chin can sing his ass off see
singing and dancing is the the number
one thing that goes viral on tick tock
one on tick tock i'm gonna have to go
chin i'm sorry nick thank you
johnny but i did shout out your podcast
that's true we'll see everybody follow
me
[Laughter]
you'll all see but we do have a king in
the sting
tic tac it's king of the sting
underscore cause always